(bass drums punctuate)
(upbeat house music)
(hardcore dubstep music)
(guitar note repeating)
♪ Feel like a pig has
done a shit in my head
♪ Skull full of pain
and mind full of dread
♪ Try to recall but the
memories take flight
♪ Something terrible
happened last night
♪ Or did I dream it
♪ Feel's like a monkey's
had a wake in my brain
♪ So do I
♪ And I've been been sleeping
in a suspicious stain
♪ That might be mine
♪ Last night was crazy
♪ Feels like I've
been in a fight
♪ Something terrible happened
♪ Something wonderful happened
♪ Last night
(night vocally repeats)
♪ The party's swinging
in like a wrecking ball
♪ People getting naked
for no reason at all
♪ Girls puking up
and tongue-tied bros
♪ Awful Andy's telling
all his racist jokes
♪ After the after-after party
♪ I met a guy
♪ Right
♪ Made bestie friends with a guy
♪ He's made me come
over all Michael Buble
- Mate it sounds like you've
cum all over Michael Buble.
♪ He had awesome tattoos
♪ Like what
♪ Devil ladies with boobs
♪ Classic
♪ But it was his magnetic pull
♪ That made me come
all over Michael Buble
♪ Although he would not stay
♪ He gave me this
one-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ What the fuck is that
♪ One-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ It looks like it
been drawn by a child
♪ Although its slightly blue
♪ That looks so fake
♪ It's still a
one-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ Yes definitely one of a kind
♪ We danced until dawn
♪ Wrestling moves on the lawn
♪ We had far too much to drink
♪ And now I'm covered in his ink
♪ One-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ That everyone
in the Navy's got
♪ One-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ Do you even know
what that means
♪ Covered in pus and goo
♪ Just Googled it,
it means (bleeps)
♪ It's a one-of-a-kind tattoo
♪ Take it away feet
(taps vigorously)
(clomps horrendously)
(taps magnificently)
♪ Although he will not stay
♪ I'll keep him close always
♪ 'Cause when I'm feeling blue
♪ I'll have my
one-of-a-kind tattoo
- Or several of the most
common tattoos in the world.
- You know what mate?
It doesn't bother me.
I'm proud of my tattoos.
And I wouldn't change
a single one of them .
(sniffs)
I'm smellin'.
(laughs)
- Guys.
- [Ash] Hi Dru.
- Guys, something
happened last night.
- I know, Ash got
some terrible tattoos.
- It's not that.
It's something much worse.
- What do you mean?
- Last night,
- [Ash and Stef] Yeah?
- After the party.
- Well, after the after party.
- Yeah?
- I think I killed someone?
(suspenseful music builds)
(upbeat house music)